so you said the animals are happiest in
the wild
and that's where they find meaning uh
what about us
the human animal what's the meaning for
us do you think
if you've uh monitored the life cycle of
a lot of living beings you ever look in
the mirror and think like
why the hell are we humans here ah
i mean thriving reducing suffering um
creating goodness i mean those are the
things i see in in
animals behavior they're mostly
interested in
in reducing suffering and and
um nurturing right those are the things
that i think evolutionarily
and we humans are just clever we want to
be able to try to do that
at a bigger and bigger scale like
as much as possible reduce the suffering
in the world
and somehow that alleviates us of our
own suffering
that's the russian thing life is
suffering and somehow helping others
alleviates it and come up with creative
solutions to do that that's really
interesting
it's almost consciousness is the thing
that
led to suffering but it also led to the
desire to alleviate the suffering
it's a it's a feedback loop
consciousness creates suffering and the
desire to alleviate it
you